what's up everybody uh we've been locked
up for a long time and now i'm finally
getting on the road again so i hope to
see you uh me and chrissy d if you don't
know will be in dallas san antonio
houston st louis columbus and on new
year's eve in cincinnati that's the
whole week after christmas uh and then i
will be on tour solo in des moines
indianapolis cleveland san diego la
burlington a second show added at
foxwoods detroit pittsburgh albany
washington dc which is really tyson's
virginia madison wisconsin and chicago
uh all in jan in february all of those
are on sale right this second at
savocanocomedy.com
can't wait to see you guys god bless
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds hello
taste buddies welcome to the taste bud
podcast my name is sal volcano and i
have with me brian quinn that's right
joe derosa looks a little different
today uh we are lucky enough to have bq
on with us which will be fun hopefully
more in the future joe derosa is tending
to joey rose's bar duty this
[Laughter]
let's do is can i do that just yeah i'm
going to just get wild i'll just get
wild
um
so
uh we are we have a great guest today my
best friend yeah and uh former what say
you
uh transformer yeah not formal because
we're always active you never know what
we'll spring back we're like um herpes
in that way you know it's like you know
you come back your wedding day we're
lying dormant right now yeah yeah but uh
you guys once you stop taking your
valtrex we are there
um so yeah so joe joe could not be with
us q is
admirably filling in
uh
and
okay so we had to think about what we
would battle and as you guys know we're
gonna do a couple we might do a food one
but we thought of one that was
completely organic to us have you done
it with somebody else besides joe yet or
just he's done it without you the only
thing we've done so far if i can get it
right is ari was a guest
and
ari um
he came on and we didn't know if we were
gonna do
you know ari just sits in yeah or ari
takes a side or me and him or sorry okay
it ended up that we wanted to do cereal
and joe and i's favorite cereal is the
same it's captain country berries and so
we have a list of things like that right
and so when we have that we're like oh
if we like something the same when we
have a guest we'll go against that so we
did captain crunch berries versus
uh what was it pampa honey nut cheerios
ari came in and won okay he was our
first guest
yes yes when i i was yeah when i was out
they did one but yeah that was really
and then i already sat in on one but
really uh i've never done one without
without without joe here okay this is
great it's fun and we were thinking
about what we would be able to do we
talked it out as one that joe and i
can't do because we're on the same page
with and it just hit me like a ton of
bricks
people who know us and know and know
impractical jokes and know the show and
just know our past know that you are a
cat person my friend yeah i have three
cats you have three cats
you love them i i could vouch that you
love them more than any human being but
it's true yeah it is true especially
benjamin cat yeah uh your cats are
benjamin benjamin brooklyn
and chessy yeah yeah uh lovely cats um
they're great i go to your house and an
array of personalities for the most part
i keep distance they keep distance i
remember one time in your old house when
you left real quick
at your old house and i was there i
don't know if you remember this you
gotta hit that well you left and it was
just a very quick thing you're like
right now i'll be right back i'm like
sure
cats weren't on my mind okay and i was
sitting at your dining room table and
then they all emerged yeah and they're
like people yeah they just started
coming
and i remember i called you and i'm like
we forgot you have cats like i don't
know i was frozen with fear at the
dining room table
um i'm sure i was just like just stop
being a [ __ ] or something yeah yeah so
most recently like this whole summer we
were hanging out and all through like
quarantine when i was with you yeah and
benjamin is fine keeps he's always
distant you have one cat though that's a
real son of a [ __ ] i think no no no no
uh that was that friend's cat i don't
know i was i was i was cat sitting
for a little bit
that cat straight up straight up just
went into a karate stance and started
swiping at me yeah but his claws weren't
out yeah but you know there i mean he's
playing he's showing aggression though
well he was i the cat that cat that
you're talking about he takes a little
getting used to yeah i'm not gonna say
that all cats are like you could dive in
with all of them
but that cat his name was uh richard he
he um let's call him dick
let's call him ringo
like like because because i think he was
named after um
you know ringo's real name is richard
starkey
i i actually know that i just was i was
like i was about to ask you do you mean
bring a star yeah so i think the the
owner named richard after after original
name was ringo was like i don't want to
call him ringo everybody does so much
oh that's cool so richard is a special
cat uh he is very rambunctious and he
what appears to be extreme aggression is
unfortunately him just playing uh well
from a from
from someone who's out of the loop i get
it he did what the cat that traumatized
me did the initial cat that traumatized
me was our buddy steve's cat sebastian i
believe his name was oh that's good and
he used to hang out in the in the
basement and you know how basements have
like a half wall sometimes that go
around them yeah yeah yeah well i used
to go through the back door to go in his
basement and that cat used to be on the
half wall like about like this high so
face level and i would always forget and
every time he had because he had two
dobermans that i wasn't they would they
would
apollo and like another greek name
it was it might have been juicing
and um i was scared of them because they
would come charging so i would always
come in the door very slowly look for
them and sebastian was on the half wall
would just be like crap and swipe at my
face
do you ever consider that you're in
their house
sure you're a giant lover you walked
into my house i didn't i didn't suck
upon you no no but you invited me into
your house yeah but these cats are just
chilling out in their homes and then
that's an inherent issue with them then
that's a problem well the dogs as well
yeah but the dogs well did you even say
that at stoves versus cats or did we
just get into cats i don't think we said
it i don't think you said it yet well i
love dogs i hate cats i'm scared of them
i don't like them i think they're born
of the devil and so this is the perfect
organic matchup for me and you yeah dogs
versus cats me and deroza wanted to do
it it was one of the first it was going
to be one of the very first
non-food um battles we did because we
wanted the first one to be pretty
polarizing yeah and and uh we were like
he's like but i i can't i like dogs i'm
like god damn it well i like dogs i love
dogs right but you but i have a clear
cat and i
do not like it yes yeah and so here we
are but i've been bitten by dogs i don't
hold it against dogs like i've been
terrified by dogs there was a york uh
what are those white ones yorkshire
terriers little little puffy white ones
yeah name popcorn when i was like nine
popcorn box
he barked and barked and backed me into
a corner
and and terrified the [ __ ] out of me i
was crying
really but i don't hold all the i don't
even hold ulterior it's interesting that
you say that because i have been bit by
dogs on multiple occasions but yet i
don't hold anything against dogs and i
think the reason is that when they're
not biting you yeah they're your best
friend for real they are like more like
when they're not biting you they are
doing things that cats don't do like
what they are you got some
misconceptions they are listening
counselors they listen to commands
okay you could tell them hey no sit stay
get up over there go to bed let's go
outside you want to go outside who's
that you can do all these things dogs
speak to you they listen to their name i
well i well that's what i'm saying like
the cats will do that for me
i've never seen a cat do that oh
benjamin i could have i'm not it's i
swear it's gonna sound like i'm giving
you something to make fun of i'm not
right i mean it like he will he will
pretty much do what i tell him to we
have like we have no i'm d this is
what's happening i don't think it's
documented that cats can understand [ __ ]
like that they can be trained i think
they write their own rules no i never
see a cat trainer ever
what are you talking about we were in
key west we saw that
there was a guy who was doing the cat
stunt show at the dock
a cat stunt shot there's a guy stunts
yeah there's a guy in key west uh
no this guy he's like super dave osborne
look we were in our 20s the first time
we went okay yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that guy was there i was in key west a
few months ago and he was still there no
yeah he's a guy he he has these um you
know you go into pet stores and they
have like those various levels of cat
houses where they're like tall and short
and they have holes in them and the cats
as well yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they have like carpeted ones
so he sets up like three of those and
then he just this like he'll go i mean
the way he speaks to the cats and goes
yeah
yeah
yeah that's right
he has to adapt to the cat no he's the
showman oh is that him
oh my god key west sunset cat show
this is him i've never seen anything
it's like a circus cat i've never seen
anything like this i think that's him as
a young as a young man
yeah i have never seen
oh man that would be so you've been
there enough i have never seen a cat do
tricks listen to commands do stunts put
on a show i see dogs all the time i once
in key west
this is him
wow i heard the rumor about this guy is
he put three kids through college doing
this show oh i thought you're going to
say like he put three cats
through a meat grinder
it sounded ominous i heard a rumor about
this guy
yeah i i he's collecting dollars see
that cat turn around this is a that's
tax-free
no no
you labeled them cat stunts no no that's
that's look this oh my god right okay
let's tell them what we're watching
first of all the opening trick was the
cat turned around
the cat did at 360. i was about to mock
it because he has to win over people
like you that think cats can't be
trained he's got to show no but you
called him stunts and then the cat he
was like yeah and then the cat just
turned and i was like well that's not
very impressive and the next split
second he lit a flaming loop
okay yeah that's a big graduation from
an about face yeah and that cat
[Music]
i think we just missed oh he there he
goes sets the loop on fire look that
kick can't wait to do the trick
that's not a stunt
okay
that's not a stunt okay he did land on
the other pedestal
because the thing is the thing is the
guy i don't know first of all the flame
is true came to you and said we want you
to jump through a flamethrower
and you said no yes
i i will say the flame is a low flame
it's not blaring so much i don't even
know if the cat come on i don't know if
it's a windy day look at how windy it is
look at how windy it is that's that and
i'll tell you one other thing i've
noticed and this guy's doing all right
he's cheating a little bit his his
flaming hula hoop is on a stick and when
the cat jumps he moves the stick to
accommodate the cat in the air but that
means
but we're not talking about the level of
confidence in gentlemen we're talking
about can cats be trained
okay okay well
i mean all right now he has three kids
cat jumping from kid to kid like bridges
that's funny that's weird yeah there's
children the cat's jumping on all of
them to get to the next one this guy is
so old now remember the guy on the ferry
used to be like shane
he looks like that after college yeah
shout out to that guy if you're watching
them you aren't because i think you've
done it god bless you we love we love
you you're part of new york and part of
this very part of my life i'll never
forget it yeah i i i've got many shines
from him yeah i only did one and i felt
so bad about it but somebody did try to
rip him off and i chased the guy down
and really yeah me well me and a bunch
of other being like four other people oh
everyone would rally behind that yeah
yeah so there's this guy so he when we
were growing up he was on the ferry i'd
say what 25 years of my life felt like
my whole life when he was 25. and he
just walked around a little old guy i
don't really know if he's from italy
great english no shang yeah that's all
he would say he'd walk around with a
shoe shine box like an old school like
one that's in the museum that's in a
museum is it the shoeshine box in the
stand island museum oh that cool yeah i
still have my grandpa's of that exact
thing yeah
i have it now but the guy would just
walk around and just go
he'd stay on the ferry all day long
because the businessman going back and
forth like when i worked at i worked in
an office from 90 late 99 to like 2002
and every once in a while i'll get my
you just would do it it would feel good
too it always felt good to get a shoe
shine
it's like getting a haircut you know you
feel like a new man
you feel sharp and then it's also
there's this like massaging effect
because he's he's really like he was
like a he was like oops
like he did it really well no nonsense
man it was like sounds like a guy with
thick hands yeah yeah yeah
gnarly
yeah like under the nails was a lifetime
of of uh yeah of wax but he would just
go shine that's all he said shine shine
and then you just go like you hail like
a cab it's start i remember being 250
and then when he retired was like five
dollars right it was always reasonable
yeah he always gave him way more than he
like you know double
two dollars a game before i wonder how
he like stumbled on that hustle like how
did he i i the the local people did an
article on him i think he was from
naples and he came here and just
just entrepreneured his way into it and
i remember as a kid
when i was a kid kid oh no tax
actually no no no with the cat show
either for sure
as a kid i remember looking at him like
you know when you're a kid you you know
you could be all sorts of things like a
psycho i remember looking at the guy as
almost like
a to be pitied when i was young
and then as i got older my respect for
the guy grew
through high school to the point when i
was in my 20s
he was part of yeah the city a part of
staten island but even i loved that he
was part of the background of my life
but i i
respected him so much
for just the hard work and doing what he
did and going and and it it was a change
because i remember being like look at
this [ __ ] poor old fool yeah and and
then you know who knows over the 20
years he did it or more than i remember
you just we grew up we grew with them
because when you were a sad dollar
especially back in the day like
or especially when i was at that age
going into the city but you took the
ferry i took the very every day for five
years so you saw them every single day
you know some people take the ferry
every day for their whole lives
but uh
yeah he no pun intended but i read the
profile on him and they said they did a
profile they said that he put his kids
through college i know that was like you
know that's what everyone's heard about
him yeah so i was just going to say he
put his he uh his kids to college on the
heels that's great man on the heels of
uh
yeah i wish they would name a fairy
healer after he offered him wait would
you say hey i said he put his kids to
college on the heels of uh yeah
yes yeah tassels really something that's
something that you really laced up that
check
i don't know
so okay so cats can be trained but then
finally i guess one day somebody gave
him a boot
all right
let me stop we love him we love him i
love him
he's dead now his soul is up in heaven
is it crazy that
i hope so
yeah to this day like late at night if
you go in the battles on the ship you
hear shine
um
he uh he um
wasn't gonna say about him
oh come on wherever oh
too i was going to say because wasn't
there like an alternate there were two
it was like gallagher and gallagher too
yeah because i was like isn't it wild
that in those three four decades however
long he did it nobody came up because he
didn't have i don't even he wasn't like
he didn't have a permit i don't think he
had no permit you know no no that's not
true later later in life he had to get a
permanent okay yeah but but but no he
didn't need a problem right he was just
like nobody was gonna mess with him he
was like no let him do his thing yeah
but that means anyone could have like he
had nothing in papaya proprietary about
it so somebody could have went on i've
been like shine you know
[Laughter]
yeah
sheep of shine yeah i know he had a
brother i remember the brother as well
he was slightly taller
um but he wasn't nearly as dedicated
yeah yeah
but we how the hell
did we do we have a string hanging here
somewhere i don't see anything
how the hell did we get on the shoe
this guy oh the cat guy the cat guy i
think so which one to wonder so you i
think i think you're in a minority when
you say that your cat listens to you
listens to commands listens to his name
i think that's a reputation cats have
but if
but look benjamin is an exceptionally
smart cat okay and i can communicate
very well to him and he could
communicate very well to me
but what
if
cat people are the same you're crazy man
because if i told you that my dog wanted
to go outside and looked at me
and i knew that he wanted to go out yeah
you wouldn't even blink i'm telling you
dogs just are smart
dogs dogs speak languages smarter than
dogs i think cats are like they are
they're natural predators i think they
true they are crafty yeah uh they make
do they can live on the streets
they're efficient they're wily they're
they might be keen but maybe in their
smartness they they make a decision
somewhere along that to neglect
their caretaker or their or their owner
yes they do because i've i've have a yes
yeah but yeah but i think i i think
you're one of those people who really
like just maybe has a connection because
my whole life i've seen thousands of
people and just they have absolutely no
connection to that cat that does not
listen to them it does not it doesn't do
anything that you wanted to do they call
it look at you go the other way there's
no jurisdiction for 95 percent of cat
owners it is my belief that there is no
jurisdiction over that animal that they
have whatsoever whereas a dog
i think the other way around i think 99
of owners are like
go on the bed go upstairs you want to
eat what's the matter something's wrong
you want to go outside who's that sit
stand roll heel jump anything you want
and i mean that's like i don't i walk
into a house and everybody can make
their dog do all of those things
everyone and so it's not even like it's
like par for the course whereas a cat i
was shocked when you were like well let
me tell you something my cat listens to
me yeah it's not what i see as the norm
yeah but but
what you're doing is is is is wrong you
you're doing is wrong i'm trying to
educate you
you're you're i don't want to but you're
painting an entire species with the same
brush
but it is but it is the it is the mo
right
it is the the top-line mo of cats i
don't i don't they're sickle finicky
they play by their own rules i like i
don't like they don't they don't respect
personal space even if i don't know you
a cat will walk up to me and worry how
many dogs come up and slobber on you
yeah but they're coming over for
affection
but
we're not talking about the reason they
approach one and cats are coming why do
you think cats are coming over
to you but a dog won't all right so a
cat if cat comes over both things it's
going to hit you with its head yeah so
both things which is trying to get you
to pet it both forks in the road with a
cat in front of me i don't like one is
i'm going to grind you
and i don't i don't know you i just
they're going to grind they're going to
grind up against you that's the
equivalent of grinding for me okay that
was like if i'm in a club dancing and
that guy comes up to me behind me to
grab me i'm like no
i told you to stop going to those clubs
that's the reason why give it a dog
and again i i don't want to make it
sound like i don't like it
i'll jump up on your dog
once that tail starts going it loses not
a trained dog i think any cat will rub
against me no matter what you say
they'll come and they rub and then they
get their hair on my pants yeah but
that's it feels weird it feels weird
it feels like to me it feels like some
part of it is sensual to them
it is a scent
scent shul because it's rubbing it's
getting it's okay it's kind of like but
it feels like you don't rub on someone
like that unless you want
you think that these issues that you are
having are really on the cat because
you've seen very odd angles
your approach here is very unusual like
i mean
sensual
they they they'll come back with a bird
in their mouth bird birds are harbingers
of disease
how long do you think you got
before you stop feeding the dog before
it reverts back to the wolf
that dog's your friend as long as you're
kept happy my friend but there's a
[ __ ] point where you were going
wouldn't that be with anybody like if me
if we were all on a deserted island then
we didn't have enough food i think we'd
get it irritated
i feel like i would become like i would
think i would have a fight with you guys
like i'm not your friend right now
because i'm hungry i've been very hungry
i'm starving my point i don't hear it
they have breaking point there but but
you can't you is this what you do with
joe every time where it's like you you
just dismiss every you don't even like
you're just like yeah but
you're taking pot shots at me all right
now we're getting into it no i'm asking
because no joe's the one that makes
blanket statements like you've never
seen a single person alive train a cat
like it's like what yeah but but
everything i say you're like you're like
uh cats they come up on you and i'm like
well dogs you're buying your two and
you're like yeah but and they go rub on
you of course
despite protest in a sensual manner 99
of the time no one has dr you're the
only person that has dragged sensuality
into this
my cats have never given me a sensual
feeling i get a sense of sensuality i do
i feel like you
of their body into mine i i don't like
that but dogs will jump on you and hump
your legs i've seen dogs hump legs
i've never seen a cat that's true about
the humping
but i've never seen a cat home a dog's
natural disposition is jolly happy come
play with me i like you a cat is keep
away from me until i let you know it's
okay
and honest honestly
don't just attack i don't like another
thing how cats will just like if a cat's
over there all of a sudden a cow will
leap up right here and then be right in
my face and then and then i also don't
like to wake up all sudden spazz out and
they just start going
and they just take swipes at you and
then you get in the weed that you give
them what is that the cat weed and then
they add nip catnip and then forget
about it i didn't know that did that i
never knew what cat name was then one
time you took catnip on the floor in
your house oh how great was that
look like they were at a rave yeah it
was insane that's awesome they were
acting very very erratic
even that's why you what happens when i
give you the human quote of cat and if
you get erratic too no but why you
they're already on they're already
they already play by their own rules
they're already unpredictable you're
gonna get dude they're gonna drug them
up i live with these cats
and i'm just telling you how it is yeah
so you interpret this however you want
yeah i live with these cats their
roommates
to a degree that i know
i can tell you where they're gonna be
the predictable animals i know where
they're going to be i know what they're
going to do i know how they're going to
act when something happens they're just
like dogs it just creatures a habit
you're coming into
situations where you don't recognize
their
patterns i mean if we're talking about
meeting an animal for the first time
i'll grant you that dogs are probably
friendly up match but i didn't realize
that was a discussion
oh it's cats versus dogs baby anything
you want is on the table okay well then
as i'll tell you who needs a lot less
attention okay
okay
that's
okay you know what i see that as a plus
except the reason you get a pet is for
companionship exactly i feel like they
are a companion when they want to be a
companion whereas a dog is like i will i
will walk by your side i mean why is it
a saying that a dog is a man's best
friend
great publicity
really but you don't think it's born out
of the fact that they are negative oil
where a cat is like it's a pack
cat is more like [ __ ]
no
some cats yes but some dogs as well cats
are fancy you know like cats are not
fancy all my cats i found in gutters and
streets
though once they get in the house don't
put on airs what is it
why do you think they're sensual what is
this they walk around
look at you like there's some sort of
regalness and they're better than you
true or false
false i've never looked like a cat and
thought that cat
thinks it's better than they don't pull
this out of my ass no i see any
recollection in what i'm saying at all
what what's happening is i'm starting to
like actually get a little worried about
you because never have i looked at a cat
and be like well this is sensuality
happening i never have i thought a cat
thinks it's better than me yeah that's
his weirdest thing like a
turnip thinks it's better than me like
it does every time i see a cat i think
this is a regal usual cat that is a
[ __ ] that thinks it's better than me
you think it's in the house what about
the [ __ ] in the house it's the
greatest thing ever the [ __ ] of life
the shitty of the house is the greatest
thing ever most people also do not have
their cat smells in the house under
control you do i would never even know
you have accounts yeah but that's just
that's just cleaning a little bit
sometimes i walk into a house and the
house if the house if the house was one
of those pine trees that hangs in a car
the house would be like cat piss and
[ __ ] smell yeah and then you just see
tumbleweed her hair going like yeah but
i'm getting a dog on his house with his
clumps of hair everywhere and and
fine but i think cat owners why did he
used to [ __ ] in the house all the time
why does it seem that cat owners collect
cats
well i'll tell you what that's odd
you know no one's ever like except joe
gatto who has 19 dogs which is
i mean we have to think about this
we have to have a talk with them think
about that i know it's ridiculous
nineteen i know he just he's my role he
might as well live in the mountains but
joe is at the point where where and it's
admirable him and betsy are just saving
giving old dogs a place to die in
comfort yeah i know so that nineteen
number just true it goes up and down
it's a noble thing yeah it's like the
stock market yeah cats are look because
really there's very little difference
between having one cat and having three
cats in terms of care of the cats
three dogs is insane they go on
autopilot they're on autopilot really
the whole trick to cats is making sure
you take care of their litter box you
have to stay on top of the litter box if
you don't you get that smell okay okay
let that smell i i don't know
i have a weird i had glasses you had
your glasses yeah i brought up why dogs
are a man's best friend also i wanted to
ask you guys what's the weirdest pet
you've ever owned
have you guys ever done a snake
uh no i never really would do a snake or
anything like that i like animals i
could hold i i had a rooster i lived in
my yard yeah for a while in an apartment
no no stan island yeah
so my sister had a chinchilla for a
minute a hot men and i also had a snake
quote unquote it was snakes that i used
to catch
i used to catch them garnet gardens
garden snakes and uh stan i was rife
with them yeah when i was little
everyone we we all had one summer we had
a phase and everybody would just go out
hunting snakes every day yeah and we'd
get five gallon buckets
same [ __ ]
in our stupid minds i threw rocks dirt
and leaves in it dropped a snake in
there and i'm like natural habitat done
like i don't even know what that was i
took an old toy chest and did it filled
with dirt and and the grass what are the
garden sticky
like
they'll eat like crickets they'll eat uh
like
centipedes and [ __ ] like that okay yeah
because we got it in a bucket and my mom
was like you're not bringing that in the
house we lived in an apartment building
yeah and the apartment building was a
walk up
and uh my mom was like you're not
bringing that in the house and i was
like all right and then i just had a
five gallon bucket in the hallway to the
opponent building under the steps or
just live snakes in there
but like for like weeks like no one's
saying and actually all the kids in the
neighborhood we lived in like these
garden departments there was like 10
buildings so that's who was our friends
growing up and everyone was hunting them
so in every building there was just
buckets of snakes
yeah and then
we would play with them we would put
them in our gene pocket walk around take
them back out yeah and one time we found
one like this big and we called him
damien because of jake the snake roberts
he was like a big like and we we had it
for a while and then like you're like
why is this snake not doing well
probably because it hasn't eaten
probably [ __ ] so long i know i mean
we were children
you know i have a question about the dog
so um why if dogs are so great yeah and
cats are not why do i have three cats
and you have zero dogs
i have zero pets
what's up buddy buddies uh i want to
talk to you about hellofresh
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit we already know that uh with
hellofresh you get fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasoned recipes
delivered right to your doorstep you can
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable all true true
true we all use it i like it that's why
it is america's number one meal kit uh
and especially right now i don't know if
i don't know if i'm coming to going
right now pimp i'm trying to get my
christmas shopping doing
i'm not eating i'm not eating right i'm
eating like i'm buying like pre-packaged
foods and eating like a savage out of
from the supermarket
but i i do try to squeeze in a couple of
hellofreshes a week uh holidays can be
hectic but hello fresh keep things
simple
recipes that cut back on meal prep and
clean up it's true and you can spend
less time in the kitchen more quality
time with friends and family or in my
case probably on amazon trying to order
something that someone won't like and
try to return
hella fresh meals are ready in around 30
minutes or less plus there's actually
quick and easy 20 minute one so
it's so funny it's like 30 minutes is
like too much they got you covered for
the 20. it's low prep it's easy to clean
you get food on the table quicker uh all
that stuff uh they have new stuff in so
they changed their their ingredients i
know a lot of times we were shouting out
a lot of these menu items they have but
they recently updated them they have
balsamic and fig beef tenderloin pk
encrusted salmon uh
chicken sausage and sweet potato soup
which is good uh
entertaining
they got you covered with options like
holiday cheese and charcuterie boards
who doesn't love that and skinny dipped
dark chocolate peppermint almonds i am
one billion percent i didn't know about
that i'm putting that on my next order
go to hellofresh.com tastebuds14
and use code tastebuds14 for up to 14
free meals and three free gifts which is
the best deal in town that's
hellofresh.com tastebuds14
and use
codetastebuds14 for up to 14 free meals
and three free gifts
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
what's up taste buddies let's talk about
light stream okay the holidays are here
this year give yourself the gift of
extra money in your pocket pay off your
credit card balances and save with a
credit card consolidation loan from live
stream
roll your high interest credit card
payments into just one payment at a
lower fixed rate livestream's credit
card consolidation loans have rates as
low as 4.98 apr with auto pay and
excellent credit
get a loan from 5 000 up to 100 thousand
clams casino that's dollars and just say
i call them clams there are no fees
and you can even get your money as soon
as the day you apply
i don't see anything wrong with that
that's two pluses livestream believes
that people with good credit deserve a
better loan experience and that's
exactly why they deliver
so you know what's coming just for our
listeners apply now to get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get the discount is
to go to lightstream.com
taste buds l i g h t
s t r e a m isn't that funny
just do two letters at a time like i
can't follow yeah
there's a kevin james bit where he's
like when people say their number and
it's like you gotta go da da da da but
then he's like you ever have someone
tell you numbers like four one eight
five six
seven two four five
l i g h t s t r e a m dot com
livestream.com taste buds subject to
credit approval rates range from four
point nine eight percent apr to nineteen
point nine nine percent apr and include
a point five percent auto disk auto pay
discount lowest rate requires excellent
credit of course terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit light light stream
visit lightstream.com tastebuds for more
information
all right but why do you have no dogs
well because i i can't have a dog right
now i travel too much
what's that i travel a lot too oh most
of the time you and i travel the same
amount into that trap yeah so what do
you mean you're saying
well how long can you be away from the
house that your cats will self-sustain
well well
at one point are they like you know
what's weird about dogs i will tell you
something yeah i feel terrible although
they have that separation anxiety and i
guess cats don't have that or they do
well because they feel like you ever see
i saw a video one time of a guy that
when he left his house he showed the
video of his dog and his dog was
freaking out like they don't know you're
gonna come back buck did that he used to
tear up the couch he used to really get
really like when you come home and
they're like oh my god yeah they're all
like how long can you be away from that
dude do cats get to that point
benjamin
i know look i i i am toning down my
relationship with benjamin because i
don't want to make it seem like it's a
bit it's not he he if if i'm not around
he he'll look for me
and he'll look for me like he'll he'll
go to rooms that he knows i'm in and
look for it and he's the one where if i
walk in the door he he comes he comes to
me right the other cats just kind of
like look at me and whatnot right so you
got yourself a special cat there but
you're applying benjamin's
benjamin's uh abilities and benjamin's
all of his
the wonderful things about him to all
cats no no no look brook brooklyn is
very stupid and i mean that and it's
like this she is the dumbest cat
and like even the vets like this cat has
to be
so inbred that it it's like she will
she's but in it she's almost like
cute because how stupid she is like
comic relief forgets where to go like
she'll get lost in the house she doesn't
like being alone if i'm not around her
i'll hear her start crying and i have to
come up wait how do you know if she's
lost i
i'm telling you i'll just watch you just
find her with a thumb out like no
direction like like she'll just be
crying and then i'll come over and be
like what's up baby okay and then she'll
just trot over and stop but like she
like all right like you know how so the
way my house is i have like a like a top
like a level that's open and you could
see down to the to the thing and there's
stairs that wrap up for the second floor
it's almost yeah it's like a foyer and
you come up the stairs to the second
level and like brooklyn i'll get i'll
lean over the top and like the stairs
are over here and and i'm over here
right looking over the foyer and now
this cat walks up down the stairs every
every day of his life all day right and
i'll be like brooklyn how you doing baby
and she'll look up not sure how to get
down you won't know how to come up the
steps will like come up to me and look
around and start getting like agitated
and like look and i'll go brooklyn look
i'll start going look at the steps over
there baby look at the steps over there
and she'll just freak out and then i'll
slowly walk over to the steps and she'll
follow me and then her eyes will catch
the steps
and then she'll be like oh yeah and then
come up this step i mean she is
dumb dumb i will put the food plate in
front of her and and and she will like
she'll if i don't put it down right in
front of her if i put it here she looks
up at me
and i have to be your plates right there
sweetheart and like exhausted yeah like
i'll have to move the plate near her and
she'll look at it and start eating i
mean she is like dumb where'd you find
such a dumb cat chief i found there i
was driving on the bqe oh my god by
atlantic air you know when you're
driving atlantic avenue it goes to that
brick like channel type thing with you
oh no no no i was driving on the way to
work and uh and i was driving in and it
was i thought it was a rat at first in
the middle of the road
and uh it was nuts it was it was i was
going 60 miles per hour so i stopped
traffic on the on the bqe right in front
of atlantic avenue and i you know i
stopped all the traffic and and it's
between the two brick walls so there's
no effort there's no way she was so
brave she was like there was a divider
in between the two lanes of traffic and
she was trying so hard to jump over and
that's when i was like that's not a rat
that's a kitten
stopped traffic and a fruit truck pulled
up and uh she jumped into the engine of
the fruit
and started burning her little paws
and she was going meow meow meow she was
only five weeks old she was this tiny
kitten so i grabbed her and we went to
florida that night we were going from
set to the airport so i had someone
bring it to the vet and i and we were
going to florida for shows and i said to
the vet look i'll pay for whatever it
needs we got to find her home i already
had two cats at that point i'm like i
can't have another cat and then when we
were in florida um the vet called them
like you you're never giving away this
cat this is the sweetest sweetest cat in
the world and she was she's just like an
adorable little uh she's sweet she would
never attack she would never do anything
like that
she's a lot like a stuffed animal a lot
of times when i pass a cat this happened
when i used to live when i used to live
uh yeah in my few apartments ago and i
lived in the back of the driveway yeah
and i used to go down this driveway to
get to my thing and uh there was there
would always be a cat there like not the
same cat but like a lot of times the
same cat yeah or and it would be in the
driveway and i would have to walk like a
good 50 feet down the driveway and then
turn to get to the door where i lived
and the cat would just stay there and i
would never want to pass it because
every time i ever pass a cat like i
would say eight out of ten times i pass
the cat they do that thing with their
back right where they go up where they
are like i'm about to attack you it's so
aggressive but how many times have you
been attacked
well
like physically attacked yeah
not menaced
well menacing is menacing is not a
threat of like an attack
is medicine is adjacent to attack but in
but you're not understanding like you
you this is
some arrogance about you where you're
like it's your it's it's your world and
it's your driveway but you're walking
down driving that's the cat's driveway
that's why i'm afraid to walk by it and
but and i go please you know go
just want compliant animals compliant
but like how do i get to my door then
you just walk past it no because it's
going to attack me but did you get past
i don't wanna if i see uh if i see a a a
a a hooligan in the street with a you
know holding a holding a weapon or
whatever and i'd know that hooligan's up
to no good i'm not gonna cross the
street i'm not gonna press but i'm gonna
go on the other side i think you look at
people who aren't hooligans and think
they're hooligans
i think cats are hooligans i don't think
cats are gone and i said to the cat
shoot get out of here get out of here go
go go any little thing
and it just stayed there and then i and
now you're menacing and then i gotta go
buy it then as soon as i go back
five minutes gesturing wildly at it and
screaming at it
like how is it not supposed to feel
threatened by you a creature that's ten
times bigger than it
like what are you talking about but
you're not giving any credence to
anything i'm saying i i understand what
you're saying but i think you're
overblowing it why don't we try this
just just for fun
what do you like about dogs i don't mind
kittens all kittens are the best because
they're you loved brooklyn i broke
brooklyn i don't feel threatened by
kittens but once it gets full cat
now if you if you met if if you raised
that kid and it wouldn't turn into a
cathy you know jesse jesse is uh
he he well he has no claws
he was the claw before i got him yeah
but yet he still swipes they still swipe
right because they're not trying to hurt
you i understand what you're saying
that's an unpleasant thing but
but i mean i mean we could complain
about these things but like would it
like a dog like i think there's a lot
more similarities than you think like
what do you like about a dog we'll break
it down one by one let's be positive
about it okay okay
i love that a dog is always happy to see
you i love that a dog is insanely loyal
i love that a dog will follow you from
room to room it'll stay near you i love
that the dog will protect you at any
cost i love that a dog
let's sing one by one all right all
right you like your dog is happy to see
you fetch
yeah but you can choose
like a toy with it cats do the same
thing yeah they'll they'll they'll you
get a little mouse toy you throw it
they'll bring it back to you and all
that stuff that's fine but do you have a
can you pull up something for me man of
course is that video i mean just go to
youtube so i wanted to hit those things
you were putting up there were probably
some good talking points but i i missed
them all
um could you find that video of like a
cat protecting the child from the dog
have you ever seen this video oh yes i
have it runs out of nowhere out of
nowhere yeah
it is that is that's it so this is a dog
that that's menacing a toddler
and and this cat
because it's bonded to a family just
like you're saying the dogs are
comes out and saves this country the dog
goes to run up on a kid right and then
the cat just goes yeah [ __ ] is like
get away from my kid
oh this is like
like what's that dog doing
look at that dog is the dog really gonna
attack the kid though it's not dragging
oh my god oh my god okay the dog is
happy look at that
that's amazing and the cat even looks to
the girl to make sure she's all right
before he goes after the dog again
oh he keeps chasing the dog
and the cat is
well that may be the best pr you have
for cats ever right there
that was wild the dog grabbed the kid by
the pants knocked him to the ground
started dragging him out of the driveway
a cat jets out of put in hero cats oh
you could probably show this right
because there's no audio
yeah and it just jets out i love that it
jets out takes like it just goes
looks back you're good and then runs
after that yeah well that was a great
cat and a [ __ ] dog but if we're playing
the numbers the actual statistics show
me the statistics
not what you've made up in your head
with the sensuality and all that stuff
like this one thing you haven't brought
up is how much noise dogs make um
yeah yeah you know what the problem is
pimp is that i don't i don't want to say
anything negative about the dogs i'm not
go i have no nothing against dogs i love
dogs but i understand we're we're in a
battle here but uh you're right don't
look dogs are high maintenance high high
maintenance they're walking three times
a day walking three times and getting
them exercise certain certain breeds you
got to get them exercising picking up
the [ __ ] yeah disposing the [ __ ] pick up
the [ __ ] too sure but i'd rather pick up
the [ __ ] in a beautiful park or on the
sidewalk today at 2 a.m when it's when
it's 30 degrees fair point fair play
talk to me then fan player
the noise uh yeah the the the barking
you know but cat what about when you go
to a dog park and dogs are like
they're all friends you bring a cat home
and you're like this is your new brother
or sister they're gonna live with you
and the cats are like i may kill him so
you got to keep you got to keep it i've
done that three times and they've all
they know what i'm saying you're like i
can't really hope that they accept him
otherwise if they're not they're gonna
kill him yeah but you think you don't
think there's any cases of a guy
bringing a dog home the dog's not
getting along i think after a certain
point it's like all right well bros
where were the cats as well that's what
i'm saying
you for cats for cats you say first
meeting for dogs it's after a while
they're bros aids
feline aids yeah which doesn't transfer
to humans it's just a cat virus
you don't think dogs aids dogs ates now
people get worms from dogs
would you have a dog that can give you
worms or a cat that can't give you aids
yeah all right well all right
is this is this the top 10 reasons for
someone why cats are better than dogs
okay all right let's read through
this okay
okay
a lower carbon footprint than a dog a
2009 study from new zealand
i mean who trusts is to keep who trusts
the kiwis
showed that owning a dog was equivalent
to owning a hummer
when it comes to carbon footprint
while not perfect owning a cat was only
equivalent to a volkswagen golf
that sounds like a suspect i'm telling
you cats are are
very affectionate if they love you cats
are like they're like you know who the
cats are who you know cats are cool
cat's a dom toretto
cat's a family ride or die cats live
their life a quarter mile at a time
that's it man they're like cats are
dominic toretto from the fast and
furious friends i believe that cats they
look out for their family it's your
family yeah it's above everything uh-huh
you know
really yes
yeah i'm not saying that that's not true
with dogs but i'm trying to get you all
over on the cat's side of things like
they might be able to think about when a
lot of people don't like dominic toretto
he thinks who he is
he barges in he thinks he owns the place
he roughs people up
he's got a real graspy voice i'm not
going to take seriously the opinion he's
fancy
yeah but do you how much you would you
even want to spend time with anybody
that doesn't like dom toretto in your
personal life then no i wouldn't
because i i somehow
somehow dominic torreira got his hooks
in me yeah his claws you me the entire
world i i i you're up to the face of
furious 200. yeah yeah yeah you know i
just he's the right amount of camp
he's i don't know what it is it's rough
it's it's it's i mean no no disrespect
diesel but dominic i mean that that
franchise we did it we did it we did a
what would you call it we did a 9 10
episode we we
did a watch along with every single fast
and the furious movie yeah uh on our
podcast except for tokyo drift we still
owe them together
uh but we did it so we ever every single
episode was
a movie and we'd watch we'd say all
right ready everybody hit um hit start
and then hit pause at 20 minutes and
come back so you guys did like mystery
science theater
pretty much so we watched in 20 minutes
and we tell the instructions for them to
watch the 20 minutes at that moment so
that the second in real time that we
came back we all watched the first act
of the first 20 minutes then we
discussed it and we did that through all
of them yeah and
we we did it so much that they contacted
us paramount contacted us we did a
screening of fast aid and we we hosted a
screening of fast date we filled the
theater
so much fun and then and then we watched
it with all the fans we hosted it we all
saw over the first time and then we went
from the theater to gotham comedy club
everyone from the theater all 300 people
went to gotham and then we did the live
pod about about festivals we used to do
[ __ ] like that
we did a field trip with our listeners
to see gallagher oh that was so much
yeah we used to then we went to sing
karaoke afterwards with them yeah
yeah yeah we we we that was like earlier
that was because we started a podcast in
2013. so we were doing like some pretty
uh adventurous stuff
jokers got so busy and we started
touring so much that are kinda yeah
wow that's awesome but but but just to
finish my analogy i don't know my if
we're running out of time
i'm gonna give you a little softball
wait wait i mean you could pit bulls you
could you could get you can get yeah
they have bad pr i would i would defend
it but you got you you take hits of dogs
if you want put i'm ready
so it's alright i'll get back to this
i'm just saying like
cats are like dom toretto and dogs are
like jim carrey's character and the
cable guy oh
that's what i think it is
like just eager to please in your face
when you don't want it you ever try to
have sex with a dog around
like that dog's [ __ ] trying to get in
that dog's trying to turn it into a
[ __ ] three-way really yeah that dog's
on the bed you got to push it off have
you had this experience yeah yeah i mean
you don't think a cat's gonna jump on
the bed oh i i have gotten busy with a
lot of cats i'm not jumping on the bed
oh you see that's another thing i would
never ever be able to have relations in
front of of my animal well you would in
front of a cat because you wouldn't even
know it was in the room
i don't like that another reason i don't
like cats you just give me more reasons
i don't want to be spied on yeah
well i don't think it's looking at you
you you think it's very sensual but i
don't think it's looking at you in that
way how could you even i couldn't even
be in the in the mental state
to do anything if a cat was just perched
up just like
yeah but if it's sleeping if it's
sleeping at the other end of the couch
it's now on the same bed yes on the
couch it's sleeping over there man you
can't do that sound off in the comments
if you're a pet owner and you don't mind
if your dog cat or pet comes into the
room jumps on the bed is walking around
the background do you let your pet do
you let your pet
be in the room when you are having
intimate moments do you do that let me
know sound off i do it i'm not ashamed i
think that maybe people get numb to it
but i think my first position on that is
that that is
weird and unsettling
well i i just know that when i make love
[Laughter]
i'm so focused
on her pleasure oh
god i mean how many [ __ ] do you need
in the room
as many as i can get normally
[Laughter]
normally hey guys let's talk about all
birds right now if you don't know all
birds uh is a shoe company or they were
and now they are expanding and i first
heard about them like a couple of years
ago uh i was sent a pair of all birds
actually
yeah i had a cold and i was like what is
this and i wore them and i had to i
would never say this if it was not true
i put them on and they were so
comfortable i could only wear certain
types of shoes because i have flat feet
i have such bad flat feet me too we
talked about feet knock knees yeah yes
right so i went to the doctor to tell my
fluffy you know what they did like they
don't like when you tell them what's
wrong with you i was like i have flat
feet he's like yeah
i told you this he's like just take off
your socks and shoes whatever this was
years ago and then he was doing
something he turned around he went oh
[ __ ]
he said that about my freak that's how
bad they are so i i used to wear
orthotics this is from a young age me
too
until shoes now the technology and shoes
started coming out that i actually could
get rid of those and just wear shoes all
birds is one of the pairs of shoes that
i wear where i need nothing else and i
could actually walk a bit i love them so
much i got my dad two pairs i got my
grandma a pair so yeah all birds make
cozy shoes in a pal from premium natural
materials that's the other thing it's
all natural they're not just comfy
they're better for the planet all birds
are gifts to feel as good to give as
they do to wear
let's see all birds performance gear
stands up to the toughest workouts the
tree dasher running shoes the natural
run apparel and new trail runners are
adorable comfy and tread lighter on the
planet uh yeah they have apparel now too
which is what i was saying that's
something i really want to check out uh
cushy wool dweller slippers
so comfortable ridiculously ridiculously
soft r r sweats
i gotta try the new sweats man if it's
anything like the shoes and new merino
wool scarves and beanies are the
ultimate cozy holiday companions they're
machine washable so they stay fresh and
clean no matter how often you wear them
free shipping and free returns my dad
throws them right in the washing machine
actually all birds is on a mission to
reverse climate change they are a b corp
making the environment a stakeholder in
their business so give comfort and feel
joy this holiday season make a great
gift i'm telling you find your own pair
or one to gift at allbirds.com today
that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot com
taste buddies let's talk about bowling
branch bowl and branch uh is an amazing
company uh that i have my sheets from
uh look
i give gifts i give really good gifts
i'm the ty i i'm not ashamed to say it
because i take pride in it i'm the guy
that has a notes in my phone and when i
hear that someone wants something or i
see something i think someone like i
keep a running list and then come
december i refer to my list bowling
branch no joke sheets i gave my mom
bowling brand sheets they're on my list
of gift giving because i always say that
we live a third of our lives in bed and
i say do not skimp on three things
footwear betting and life experience and
so betting is that important to me and
i'm telling you right now bowling branch
makes a good gift uh they are
comfortable
like a lot of times people just
accumulate sheets they're like umbrellas
like you haven't seen like i go to
people have one sheet it's not a set i
have one sheet around the thing one
pillow case with florals on it it's like
from like 1960 because you don't throw
that stuff out the best thing you could
ever do is do yourself a favor or give
the gift of a good night's sleep and buy
a fresh set of sheets i contest that the
two best feelings in the world are
getting into bed with a fresh pair of
sheets or putting on a fresh pair of
socks
bowling branch holds themselves to high
standards across the board from sourcing
pure organic cotton to putting workers
rights first and that's uh not just
their sheets uh that are made the right
way they do pillows bath towels and
robes too that's something i'm very
interested in that i have not tried yet
that i want to try their signature hem
sheets are the all-time best seller if
you're looking on the website they're
below for many reasons but they get
softer with every single wash they are
buttery soft no joke and they're
lightweight so another thing with me is
i sleep on a memory foam mattress which
can run hot and so i run hot at night so
depending on the sheets i use i wake up
sweating or not and with my bowling
branches it's a cool comfort cruise base
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the new standard embedding from bowling
branch that just come wrapped and ready
to give in this special holiday
packaging um
order by 12 19 december 19th for
guaranteed delivery by christmas
best deals of the year going on now from
december 16 to december 23rd with promo
code taste buds at bowl and branch dot
com that's b-o-l-l
and branch
dot com promo code taste buds exclusions
may apply yeah but what about like pit
bulls whether like you you can't have
certain breeds you can't bring certain
breeds around
around children it's true that's odd i
mean that's like what about this though
what about this
what about the fact that there are like
hundreds of breeds of dogs and they look
different and every cat looks the same
talk about every cat looks the same way
one's orange ones
they all kind of look the same no no
that's weird to me no could you could
pull up a russian hail cat a russian
blue look there's a puffy cat a regular
cat and a hairless cat just three cats
no no no look look at how look at how
fat and puffy this one looks but it
looks like the same as any other cat
that does not look like but if that cat
walked in the room like it just looks
like a cat they all look the same
i mean no we got the cats with the giant
hair there's a puffy cat a regular cat
and a hairless cat it's all about the
hail ant on a cat otherwise they all
just say all humans look the same but
dogs look crazy different yeah but you
know why that is is because dogs that
that's all man-made dogs don't look like
that
every breed that you're that you're
discussing is a man-made but there's
still
there's still a certain amount of nat
like breeds like the original breeds
before we did a cockapoo they came from
wolves that everything else is created
by man they're genetic [ __ ] freaks
bulldogs can't even give birth without
help
you understand that i didn't know that
french bulldogs are all one hundred
cents
like encouragement no they're not
cutting it open their heads are too big
their freakish heads are too big we've
bred these poisons bulldogs
c-sections yeah we've taken man's best
friend and we've turned them into
grotesques
yes for your amusement and for everybody
yeah are bulldogs unintelligent it's
well known that bulldogs suffer from a
variety of physical ailments that make
them particularly unhealthy and that
many are unfortunate byproducts of
breeding to the extremes of the same
physical features that win them prices
and eclipses i dated i dated a girl had
a bulldog i i was at the house one day
and the door's tear duct popped out it
was a [ __ ] red it's called cherry eye
it just rolled out of its eye and it was
just hanging there teardrop i'm like
what are you what are we gonna do about
this stop with the bulldogs yeah if
you're watching bulldog breeders and we
know that you are you gotta stop with
this not it's all it's it's all it's all
breeds and and breeding and stuff like
let me ask you this yeah westminster dog
show yeah the super bowl for dogs yeah
is there a cat equivalent oh yeah i've
been to it what is it at the javits i
think it's like the westminster catcher
there's a hole the javits center has a
whole i've gone why have i never heard
of the westminster cat show though all
right
now that's it isn't that fake is that
real
this is definitely i'm telling you i was
what about going to the park with your
dog what about going on a walk with your
dog you know
you can do cats you gotta train them to
do that but you can do that it's not as
natural to them right you're not gonna
walk with you on a leash around the
supermarket do you remember when we were
in uh when we were in uh the rainbow
what is the rainbow bar trying people
trying to walk their cats no like
remember there was that guy it was the
rain the rainbow in l.a rainbow room or
the rainbow room it's the rock club with
guns roses like [ __ ] all those girls
there was um there was a guy there with
a cat on the show remember long hair and
he invited us his house to go to his
party and we said no do you not remember
this oh yeah yeah and we were like no
and then later on not a lizard it was a
cat he had a cat that looked on the
shoulder from motorhead he's not that
was it right but we we said no because
we're like who's this [ __ ] weird dude
and then we we later found out he was
like a multi-millionaire who threw
parties with models and [ __ ] up at the
houses and getting invited to the house
was kind of a big deal and we just
[ __ ] blew it off but that guy was
living his best life with a cat like on
his shoulder you know yeah all right
well let's let's uh let's go to the
polls let's go to the phones
uh pimp yeah i i think that you're
coasting on a reputation that that dog
well this is gonna be a heated battle
because it didn't really yeah because
people love
you're you're a cat lover you're a dog
lover or both yeah but i think that i i
really don't know where the tides well
just the problem is like you you you
really have ignorance really because you
don't own a dog and you don't own a cat
i've owned dogs in my life
sure but you haven't owned a cat no and
when was the last time you owned a dog
well i have peripheral dogs but the last
time i owned owned lived in the house of
one it's been quite some time so it's 20
years i mean you you you come at me with
cliches and and and assumptions and
you're not really coming out with
anything like i'm i'm i'm giving you
white like specific examples and you're
just giving me like
you know i'm giving you what's another
garfield what i've gleaned
about a cat's reputation and my
experience with cats over my life you've
been around my cats you even said chessy
when he was sitting
over the quarantine chess he was like
just sitting on that counter by us and
you were like it's actually kind of cool
that the cat's are sitting there like
that it is
but i am afraid of cats that's the
bottom line i'm afraid of them they're
just too unpredictable for me i feel
like at any moment they'll because i i
don't like sharp objects and they have
claws and they have those teeth and
but don't you think that this is very
specific to you and you should be
painting like an entire species well
people there are people that don't like
cats and they all seem to fall in the
same reason buckets of reasoning
the the masses you know who you're the
people at large who doesn't like cats
the non-cat lovers you know
i mean we're gonna we're gonna see the
contingent soon
i don't know if there's more i gotta
believe that dogs have better pr than
cats so i think that dogs might have
been a favorite in this battle i'm not
here to even win this i'm here to let
you know and to let these people know
who might not be happy about that cats
have the same breadth of personality
and affection and intelligence as dogs
do
you are presenting as if they all act
the same and they're all do the same i'm
telling you they are not okay they are
grateful they they are fun they some
will play some will never play
it's across the board i feel like more
times than not i hear people having to
defend the cat
than people knowing that about that's
why is that because that's insecurity
a cat owner's parts all right
we're gonna go to the phones dogs
to eat or as a pet we just read a bunch
of funny comments we pick one we retweet
them we call them
out we didn't do any chance
oh we didn't do any chance if derozan
knew
by the way i assume did you see my
reaction just now it was way way way
dramatic it was cartoonish yeah yeah
what's the chance so all right so
so
jerosa all right real quick before we go
to the phones derosa comes in one day
and he goes i was thinking and uh i'd
like to do these uh chants to start off
the show and uh it's the very first
sentence he goes hey everybody it's the
taste buds one of the taste buds and
we're here we are here for t-a-s-t-e
buds
so we say that to start it
and then before we begin because he gets
so heated sometimes no does this yes he
doesn't know
like sometimes we've had such big fights
that he leaves and he's like are we good
and i'm like dude we're just doing the
podcast and he's like well i've been i
mean
he goes i've been walking around with
this he goes my mom saw last week's
episode and she asked me if we actually
didn't like each other because are you
feeling that i go no dude i leave it
when we stop i leave it i go you pissed
me off during it right so he started
doing this thing all right he goes all
right i've been doing this all week this
is what we're gonna do for now on so
before we start the show we go it's time
it's time for t-a-s-t-e yeah but we need
pause
then right before we start we put the
mics down yeah
and we hold each other's arms and we go
like this three times no matter what
happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you
and then
then we talk a little bit and then when
he's ready to kick off the episode he
goes all right it's time for b-a-t-t-l-e
buds battle buns
so all right that was kind of like
attacking me prorating got it okay
because we didn't do it uh well we don't
need it like we we we yeah yeah i don't
think people love it it was polarizing
in the beginning people stopped with a
chance and now people are like can we
get the chance on shirts do you find
that there's two audience different
audiences between taste buds and and uh
hey babe there's an event diagram
there's a lot of a lot of crossover but
there's also i call it like 25 50 25.
got it okay you know
yeah like no press
50 and then like and then you have
people that it might be occasional
watchers but like the hardcores there's
definitely people that watch one and
don't watch the other because i could
see people being put off by joe
i didn't see that coming
i know joe sees it too yeah i i love the
guy i mean i you know i haven't known
joe's that long but me and him became
such quick fast friends yeah uh which is
very difficult to do with me at this
point in my life um
and it and i it's because of his
inherent
he's like a sourness
he's like a peanuts character yeah yeah
yeah
that's the best way to describe him
isn't he yeah who's the guy that walks
around with a cloud over
yeah i always think of him as a young
larry david yeah that too yeah you can
describe the lotteries the thing is you
either go in full bore and you got to
accept him for everything right it
always spoils and toilet you got to
accept and then you then you become a
fan of all of it yes you have to become
a fan of all of it because if you don't
like half of it you're going to be like
i don't know i can't if i could take
derosa yeah but when you get on board
for the whole picture of derozan then
you you all of a sudden you're in a seat
a different seat you're like oh yeah all
of it my favorite part of atlantic city
was you had everyone boo de rosa oh yeah
end on stage yeah i i there's something
about him that i that i just like
i just i don't know man i i don't really
have that experience with too many
people these days oh my god he will
[ __ ] he will talk he will talk about
a topic ad nauseum which i love yeah
he'll sit there and debate it with you
now that's how this was born out of i
said you know how mean you used to be
with electronics yeah
trips to best buy oh we used to never
make a major purchase without calling
each other for a full consultation there
was a cut off about a number cut off if
you're spending like more than like a
hundred dollars two hundred dollars we
should get on the phone still work this
is why i want it you ever see people
call suze orman you know susie orman
or sue zorman she's like the political
analyst she's that lady with like uh
that mom cut oh yeah so people call her
on the phone and she takes it she goes
they go i want to buy an atv i'm 35
years old i make sixty five thousand
dollars a year i have twenty thousand
dollars in the bank and i'm six thousand
dollars in debt and then she like
[ __ ] rain breaks it all down then she
goes guess what you can't buy it it's
i'm addicted to her
that's how we used to be with each other
bob yeah um he yeah i i actually had me
and joe went out drinking about uh two
weeks ago with that one day we were
supposed to go to lunch we ended up
drinking until 10 o'clock at night and i
had to say to him at least twice i had
to go i'm not sal stop screaming at me
you'll be talking about nothing and
he'll try to turn it into a
full-on war and i'll be like we're not
recording i'm not saying like
not everything has to be this [ __ ] at
each other i know i know and then every
every like a dozen days you got a total
of a ledge it's great
but but it's great it really is great
he's also one of the most considerate
kind yeah yeah great legitimately uh
anyway but yeah you came to atlantic
city that's what you don't know if
you're missing if you're not coming to
see me live uh this past weekend i was
in boston and the borgata atlantic city
and q and joe were surprised guests at
the end they came out on stage so yes
you never know what's gonna happen my
tour is on sale right now
savilecanoecomedy.com we are adding
shows second shows this just i just
found this out we're adding second shows
in madison and chicago and last week we
added shows in pittsburgh
and jesus christ i can't remember pitts
pittsburgh and detroit and albany yeah
so we've added second shows and all
those and they're on sale now and
everything's going great and and
connecticut but i kind of be honest la
you got to step up
all right la's always been a tough
market yeah
except for that one and dc's weird right
now tyson's virgin really yeah i mean
we're on good pace but all these other
people we're selling out you guys don't
let don't get that reputation yeah
there was a point where we swore we'd
never play la again and then we did the
uh greek and it was just wonderful that
was my favorite show that was the
turnaround show yeah that was the center
on the left yeah uh let's see cats are
very scary even the ones that look kind
would rip your eyes out of your skull in
a heartbeat well that's not true okay
well no no no no no not okay
i believe it
no she's stating like but it's not true
all right all right god forbid you're
being burgled and things get hairy a dog
would lay its life on the line me and
while cow would be like this is between
the two of you i love that
we just saw a cat fight to the death to
save
you throw that picture up
gee i wonder which side sounds that was
a good day so i hate cats so much if you
if you don't know if you don't watch
jokers or you haven't seen that episode
they chained me down it was retaliation
because we chained you down and put
tarantulas on you they chained me down
and put cats on me and i literally
almost passed out this guy dog oh my god
i miss you you're the best person ever
and i love you cat [ __ ] you feed me 100
not true i will walk in my house and and
if one the second
all of them will do this but i just keep
going to benjamin lays an eye on me the
purring is so loud
so loud okay yeah and it's not feed me
because they have electronic feeders
that open them when i'm not home all
right let's see i can step on my dog's
foot by accident he's the one who acts
sorry i could treat my cat like royalty
and he'd make an attempt at my life
while i'm sleeping this is someone who
owns both
also more people are allergic to cats
and dogs and if you're allergic to dogs
there are hypo allergenic ones we didn't
even touch on allergies
my cat will shake the closet and clear
her throat while i am sleeping cats are
[ __ ] these are cat owners
[Music]
dog people call everyone their best
friend cat people don't have friends
cats that's not true though
a cat dogs can tell a lot about people
but most dogs i know love everyone but
the bond of a cat and its person
cats they're so chill the perfect buddy
to hang with have some catnip and dig
into a nice watery can of tuna okay cats
are those people you call friends but
really you just hang out at the same
places well i would argue that that's a
personality defect in that person okay i
love my dog so much but i also love
traveling and having dogs really
complicated that that i think is
honestly the biggest difference between
the cats dogs are work cats or not i
love cats i really hope this is one big
swerve and the guys go for the pic that
everyone thinks
they aren't going for so they wanted you
to defend me but that's not true yeah i
can't do that uh got a side with q on
this one you're all wrong for choosing
dogs i'm with you on this one love ya i
love cats uh i love that cats come potty
trained i had a cat with a right there's
that too i had a cat with autism once
yeah think about that uh that's a joke
that is that is an excellent point
though like like cats just notice [ __ ]
in that box immediate unerringly how is
that positive because they want to bury
it so what they do is they they look for
the things there's just something
biological yeah wow yeah what what are
we at right now because i think we're
going to try to shoot for an hour we're
now right down okay uh all right yeah
let's do here we go let's it's just a
humble pie segment yeah i know you're
going to win it's all i don't know i
don't know i i honestly don't know i
think it would be closer than you think
all right if you think i'm going to win
there's got to be more than 4 700 votes
but definitely we've been doing this an
hour
what that doesn't sound right oh what's
today
we've never had under 15 000 votes how's
that possible
oh you know what it is it also is a new
polling system they made me write what
to choose in the body i wonder if they
like they change the polling system no
no everything's updating okay all right
so here we go uh i don't know i truly
don't know how this is going to go i
really don't i don't because it stands
to reason they're as many cat owners as
dog owners so yeah i love his stuff i
know but i think people i think the cats
i think that does just got better do you
think it's going to be close
no
no yeah maybe
under 5
45 45
10.
so okay so yeah
okay oh under five percent would be
fifty fifty two five forty eight so
you're saying it it'll be within fifty
five forty five yeah ten percent spread
let's do it
whoa
pimp by the way voted for cats just want
to call that out yeah i was not
expecting this yeah my initial reaction
was that
it's a three to one ratio yeah 71.6
for dogs versus 28.4 for cats i will
tell you i felt that dogs would be the
favorite i did not think i did not think
it would be like that i just felt cat
people would rep the cats and dogs were
up dogs and it was about even yeah you
know i think that people americans
especially just like
feeling good about themselves like
subservient
creatures that they could boss around
and and makes them feel like they're
they're special okay i think americans
need that
[Laughter]
no i
don't all right when is this coming out
pimp
monday monday okay so uh i just have a
couple of plugs here well i'm sorry i
mean i i we didn't really go we didn't
all we didn't try and kill each other i
hope civilized conversation is fine yeah
good discourse good points being made on
both sides okay a lot of laughs you took
a couple shots you took a couple shots
yeah i know but i can never be not your
disposition yeah no but it's not about
being mean i could like yeah you know
joe is joe is just that's his that's his
square one so much it's hard for me to
to like you know do anything against
sally
no it's all good that was fun it was a
lot of fun i couldn't mean joe couldn't
do this one so um yeah so chris d and i
you already know this we tell you all
the time but we are you probably even
start at the beginning of this podcast
so you already know of it so 26 to the
31st one we're on the road in texas
missouri and ohio uh tickets are on sale
right now at chrisdcomedy.com or
salvolcanocomedy.com
uh that's the week after christmas get
us his christmas gifts come see us if
cincinnati sells out we're going out
with the crowd afterwards uh and then
savilcanocompany.com i'm in dates all
the time and yes
madison and
and and what did i say madison
and albany pittsburgh detroit added
second shows and as of today we found
that madison chicago come see me at the
vic
all right uh
this is what we say at the end of the
chance i still love you i say i still
love you buddy and then the person who
lost this i love you too okay i still
love you buddy i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds